Speaker 1: I want to propose to you today that
maybe, just maybe, Donald Trump was not the
worst president in American history. You know,
when we think about Trump and Trump's legacy,
Trump was clearly a worse president than
Barack Obama. We know that that's clear.
Speaker 3: Obama.
Speaker 1: Now. Trump was clearly a worse
president than George W Bush. He was worse than
Bill Clinton, he was worse than George H.W. Bush,
etc.. But is it possible that there has been a
worse president than Donald Trump? And I am going
to suggest to you today that that president may
have been. James Buchanan. What? Just. Just hear
it out, okay? James Buchanan was president from
1857 to 1861. He was a pro-slavery Democrat. Of
course, remember, this was before the realignment,
the party realignment. Being a Democrat then
is very different than being, you know, Adam
Schiff. Today, we're talking about something
very different. And Buchanan essentially led
the country to civil war. So let's compare and
contrast elements between Trump and Buchanan and
see where we come out on race relations. We might
call it. You know, Trump inspired and coalesced
racists of all kinds. He was extraordinarily
racially divisive. He hesitated to condemn
white supremacy and neo-Nazi ism until he had
absolutely no choice. He passed and advocated
for policies that were discriminatory against
immigrants and minorities, and he stoked racial
tensions with the rhetoric. Buchanan, however,
was for slavery. He was for slaveholders. He
endorsed the Dred Scott decision, which denied
rights to African-Americans. He pressured Kansas
to adopt a pro-slavery constitution. He supported
the secession of Southern states, which quite
literally would have ripped the United States
apart. And he did nothing to stop the violence
between the pro and anti-slavery factions.
You could say, well, David, you know, being
pro-slavery at the time was different. Fine.
Okay. But this is James Buchanan. Now, in terms
of legislatively and relationships to Congress,
of course, Trump's relationship to Congress was
a disaster. Clashing with Congress, ignoring,
defying congressional subpoenas and oversight
requests, vetoing some bills overridden by
bipartisan majorities. Okay. But when you
look at Buchanan, Buchanan vetoed many bills,
completely uncontroversial bills about land grants
and internal improvements, tariffs which at the
time were arguably necessary and uncontroversial.
Buchanan tried to actually influence congressional
elections using intimidation. You could say,
Well, Trump did some of these things, too. Sure.
But we're saying, is it possible Buchanan was even
worse? Now, when we look at crises that afflicted
each of these presidencies, Trump had a number of
crises the pandemic, the associated recession, the
rash of police brutality, incidents that
led to protests in favor of racial justice,
obviously inciting an insurrection. Comically
disastrous relationships with foreign leaders
and kowtowing to dictators. All these different
things. Disastrous handling, for sure. You know,
downplaying the pandemic, contradicting experts,
spreading misinformation, failing on testing and
tracing and all these things, lacking empathy and
compassion, all of that. But then you say, well,
look at the crisis that James Buchanan dealt with.
James Buchanan dealt with a situation that quite
literally led to a civil war which could have
ended the United States as we know it. And he
handled it. You could say Buchanan's handling of
the lead up to the Civil War was worse than Trump
on the pandemic. It's a different environment.
But you could say that, Buchanan said, you know,
secession is not illegal. Said, I have no power
to stop it. If they're going to secede, they're
going to secede. He said it's the abolitionists
fault. Those who want to end slavery are provoking
the South, accusing the abolitionists of treason,
refusing to reinforce and resupply federal forts
of all kinds, which subsequently were attacked
by Confederate forces. You could say he left.
He you could say he left union forces unprotected,
which is. Unbelievably disgusting. And he also did
nothing to stop violence in a bunch of different
a bunch of different states. So could the argument
be made that Buchanan was actually the worst
president when you think about the legacy? Yeah.
Trump was impeached twice and he incited the
insurrection and failed on COVID, all of those
things. Buchanan quite literally left a broken
nation, and I don't say that metaphorically. He
left a nation in civil war, which was trying to
break itself apart. So I think that it's really
difficult to compare 1861 to 2021 because there
are so many fundamental structural differences
that the country saw during that period of time,
of course. But I think you could make the case if
you wanted that Buchanan was a worse president
than Donald Trump betraying his oath of office
and his country and his people, which Trump did,
too. But maybe Buchanan did it in an even more
egregious way. Let me know what you think. Worst
presidents in history. Trump. Buchanan. Someone
else. Let me know in a comment. Let us know in
an email. We're going to take a very quick break
and be back after this. All of the stuff we've
been talking about today, you can find it on our
YouTube channel, on our Tik Tok, on our Instagram.
It's almost too easy to find it, quite frankly.